who comes up with this [ __ ] those are
incredible
these are incredible
[Music]
today's episode answer the internet is
presented by Romans stick around at the
end for more details what's up guys I'm
Paul verzi and I am here to answer the
internet okay would you rather your
girlfriend be able to read your thoughts
during sex
or all the all the time except during
sex oh my God I'm in trouble either way
dude I'm I'm dead either way I would say
during sex just because I'm with her and
other times you know that creative mind
can go places where I don't want her to
know so I'm gonna say during sex because
hopefully my focus is where it should be
would you rather be an NFL star or an
MLB star I would rather be an MLB star
just because I'm five eight and the the
beating my body would get during that
plus there's nothing like hitting a home
run and having that alone time around
the bases which I would milk okay I
would milk I would I'd walk to first
then throw the bat then point to people
at second so I would I would soak all
that in NFL doesn't give me that except
a concussion so I'm saying MLB would you
count to 1 million for a million dollars
uh you are locked in an empty room until
you're finished
and every time like if you're like it's
469 300 and you fast you mess up you're
going back to the beginning you've got
to count cleanly to one million but you
get a million dollars for it
would I do it yeah
yeah I would do it I would do it because
I already have mental illness with OCD
so it would be nothing different for me
because I'm always going back my mind is
always going back so I'll be like all
right I'm right at home let's get that
million I'm doing it but if you messed
up at like 97 and you were just like me
oh God yeah yeah you could have a
breakdown would you rather everybody be
naked all the time or closed all oh my
god dude have you seen some of these
animals closed all the time I just got
off the train believe me I don't want to
see any of that layers of clothes would
you rather never have to wipe your ass
or never have to shave well I'm Greek
and Sicilian so the hair comes quick so
I would have to say shave just because
if I let this go but if I let this go
six months that'd be extinct soon uh
would you rather be able to throw 105 or
dunk that's a great question but hands
down the feeling to dunk for somebody
five foot eight would just be nuts
because there are short guys that have
been able to throw fast could you
imagine me just a small all white
Italian Greek kid 5'8 with sneakers on
dunking on somebody that's what I would
do 100 two buttons you can press only
one instantly get a million dollars have
a 50 50 chance to get 100 million
dollars oh my God gambling and risk is
in my blood but my wife would [ __ ]
kill me if I said sweetie we had a
chance for a million but a hundred
million and we lost I gotta take the
million just because I know my kids
would be cool with school and college
and my wife would come plus 50 chance to
[ __ ] up is a lot I'm taking the million
I'm taking you can't be greedy 80 20 I
would risk it 80 20 I would risk it
would you rather fight Mike Tyson sound
like him for the rest of your life I'd
fight I'd have to fight him dude I I
because I do comedy for a living so I I
don't know how a long set would sound
after a while people be like I can't
take any more like I'm doing a podcast
they're like this guy's you know
um and I love Mike Tyson so no
disrespect but I don't know if I could
have that I would just take a quick
knockout I'll do he'd put me to sleep
with one but then I have my voice would
you rather edit or film a porn well I
got to tell you I've been doing a lot of
editing lately with my special and I'm
getting good at it so I'd edit I'd be
like no you got to get the shot from
this angle trust me I know I know about
lighting right now who would win a fight
10 10 year olds or 100 year olds I would
say a hundred hundred year olds just
because they would come at you like just
like an ant farm because even if they're
weak there's 10 verses 10 times then
they'd have to win that who comes up
with this [ __ ] those are incredible
these are incredible are there three
sacred days when you refuse to
masturbate a funerals tragedies
religious holidays Etc I don't like
jerking off right you asked that last
night you feel you feel ashamed of
yourself no I just said there's
something about just a grown man pulling
his pants down just cranking his own
[ __ ] that's just the most bizarre
embarrassing thing in the world like
you're you're preparing to do something
that's just you which is [ __ ] weird
to me but I would say I would never do
anything on like anything that would
like like a kid's graduation day
anything that has to do like oh I got
like if I'm taking my daughter to soccer
practice it can't happen that day
anything that I have to be a dad for
just feels shitty for that 20.
I know but if they go away
if you crank if you crank one out and
then you're at soccer practice like Dad
how's your day going like I'm all right
I didn't do much would you give up
Sports all together if your dog could
live happy and healthy for as long as
you wanted I have two one's still alive
Stanley Thomas passed here's the deal
Sports will never give me the loyalty
and the unconditional love that my dog's
sitting next to me no matter how his day
is going that he gives me so I would
have to say as much as it would be hard
well the Knicks haven't done anything
for me so that would be easy I've seen
the Giants and Yankees do it I'm taking
my dog healthy it would be tough but I'm
taking my dog they say over 50 percent
of men have some sort of problem with
their sex life whether that's getting an
erection maintaining an erection
premature ejaculation low testosterone
and that's where Roman comes in they are
the digital Health Clinic that can fix
all of these problems they have
testosterone supplements they have pills
for the erectile dysfunction they've got
the Roman swipes that help you last
longer in bed and you can get all this
at a One-Stop shop online at road.co
answer that's ro.co slash answer where
you can get the Roman swipes the
testosterone and any sort of medication
you need to fix any of your sex life
problems and you can get 20 off go to
Road dot Co slash answer today for 20
percent off all your Solutions that's
Road dot Co slash answer what was better
ages 8 to 18 or ages 18 to 28.
unfortunately in my life I would have to
say the latter 18 to 28 went through
some [ __ ] plus I kind of got my [ __ ]
together at 24. I learned how to be a
responsible human being so I would say
later because from 8 to 18 I was a mess
I think you're starting to make some
money you got a nicer car you're in your
20s you know at eight you're you know
you're [ __ ] your pants you're like
the people
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out